ويذهب الأوسكار إلى
كل شيء
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
أمي تبلغ من العمر 84 عامًا وهي
في المنزل أشاهد أمي ،
أريد فقط أوسكار
المجموعة الفنية بأكملها من الفنانين الذين صنعوا
هذا الفيلم ، لقد فزنا للتو بجائزة أوسكار
التي دعمت هذا النوع  الأفلام التي
صنعتها طوال هذه السنوات ،
الآلاف ومئات الآلاف من
الأشخاص ، فزنا للتو بجائزة أوسكار معًا ،
نريد تكريس هذا للأمهات ،
كل أمهات العالم لأمهاتنا ،
أه على وجه التحديد أمي وأبي كين
وبيكي ، شكرًا  أنت لعدم سحق
إبداعي عندما كنت أصنع
أفلام رعب مزعجة حقًا أو
أفلام كوميدية منحرفة حقًا ، أريد أن
أعترف بسياقي ،
والدي المهاجرين ، والدي الذي وقع في حب
الأفلام لأنه كان بحاجة إلى الهروب من
العالم وبالتالي تجاوز هذا الحب للأفلام
عليّ أمي التي هي روح مبدعة
أرادت أن تكون راقصة وممثلة
ومغنية لكنها لم تستطع تحمل رفاهية
مسار الحياة ثم أعطتني إياها
لجميع الأولاد والبنات الصغار الذين
يشبهونني وهم يشاهدون الليلة.
منارة الأمل والإمكانيات ،
هذا دليل على أن الأحلام أحلام كبيرة
والأحلام تتحقق.